all right what is going on everybody
welcome to another python raspberry pi
robotics tutorial video in this video
i'm just going to show you guys where i
am with my uh rc car now
as you can see we've got what looks to
be a video feed and it sure is a video
feed i added the raspberry pi camera
module to my car and i have that
streaming
uh the data to my pc now the only
problem is buffering
um there is a bit of a lag
to get back to the pc anything between
like one and three seconds about
and this is just due to probably a lot
of things uh the most important thing is
just the fact that we're working with a
raspberry pi we're also working with a
little cheap at a max wi-fi so we're
probably paying a little bit of a tax
just sending the data back even though
we are in network
and the other thing is
um
well the main i think the main reason
though is just the fact that it's a
raspberry pi okay so we've got the
raspberry pi we've got the camera module
in there we've also got a distance
sensor in there and we've got all the
gpio pins that are doing things as well
so there's a lot of things that are
going on that is plugged in at the
moment and so i think that just gives us
a bit of a lag the other thing that i've
noticed is
once we start adding like right now the
video feed's okay we're not noticing
anything too major yet
but when we start adding and working
with this script i'll run our autonomous
script here
um i think you'll notice that
the camera might even go out
we might actually drop power
um so anyway let's go ahead and see
because our power supply is actually a
thousand milliamps so i mean there's no
problem
uh with the power supply as far as like
rating is concerned but anyways let's go
ahead and
change directory into robotics and the
file that we run is robot six step high
just to see
so we'll do sudo python
robot six dot pi
and we'll let this run
i believe it starts immediately so you
can even see that it has quite a delay
i think it's actually running too even
too fast for the script actually i just
put new batteries in and it appears that
it goes a lot faster than it did before
with no batteries i hear it banging
around in the kitchen we were definitely
hitting things
um
i'll show you guys where i put the
camera it's actually in a pretty safe
spot but the distance sensor is not and
i wonder if it's hitting the distance
sensor um but i think the first thing
that we'd want to do is
oh oh it's gonna make a run for it
apparently i don't know
man these new batteries are powerful
i've never seen this thing be so uh
so strong
normally doesn't run very well
and
she needs to stop right it starts i
forgot how long we made this script
but uh
there it maybe it's done i don't know
there it finally ended
oh man so anyway yeah there's a little
bit of a delay there now uh one thing we
probably ought to do sudo nano
um
robot 6.5 because that was getting way
too close and i think like i said i just
put brand new batteries in so i have
never even seen it pivot that well
normally when we run the pivot command
um
it
very slowly pivots because it's
underpowered uh that was some serious
pivoting i am interested to see it in
person actually
um so here we go it looks like we might
actually drop our camera pretty pretty
soon once it starts doing that like gray
screen anyway i want to get to our
distance here i forget where
if current distance is less than 20
um
then we want to
run reverse but i thought we had a
longer
that's all commented out so i think what
we're running is actually
autonomy then we run the the check front
command so for the check front functions
let me find check front i think this is
check front right okay so instead of 15
we really need to make a single variable
so we're not hard coding all this if
distance is greater than we're going to
do
i guess we'll do 25 just so it actually
does something
25 25
25.
all right hopefully we don't hear so
many crashes i heard quite a few bumps
in the kitchen there and actually i
probably should check the distance
sensor make sure that it's pointing so
this incentive sits above so if it hit
something the distance sensor would
point up so let me go make sure that's
okay
okay
so it was actually aiming down a little
bit but probably not enough to influence
anything major but
definitely something that happened
so now it's definitely hitting on the
back end it looks like possibly hit on
the front end there but we're definitely
hitting on the back because it reverses
to the back really quickly
i might make a run for the from the
kitchen here in a minute
it's fighting the oven at the moment
okay so anyway as this is running i just
want to explain some of the things that
i did uh with the kit that i got from
sanesmart the
camera module actually fits
inside the front like there's that front
piece and it's got a circle i'm not
really sure what the whole cutout circle
was originally intended for but it
actually fits the raspberry pi camera
module
perfectly and so you can fit the the
camera module in there and then the lens
just barely pokes through now there's no
good way to mount the camera module
there so i just use electrical tape it
just literally taped it there
but as far as the lens hole is concerned
that was perfect so
again i'm not really sure what it was
intended for but it worked out really
well so i'll show you guys at the end of
that after this is done with its run
hearing a lot less crashes uh we do
definitely want to put
a uh
rear distance sensor in this but
otherwise
this is doing pretty good
i hear it hitting on the back but it
doesn't appear to be hitting on the
front you can even see the camera gets
out a second whenever it hits in the
back but anyway not too bad so let me go
grab it and i will show you guys what
we've got going on at the moment okay so
this is where what we have now so this
is our power supply this is the distance
sensor so obviously this is a little um
a weak point for this car
also we have all these cables out here
it'd be nice to stuff everything pretty
much in there but maybe we'll get to
that eventually but then the camera
module i'm not sure how well you can see
but it's actually this poking through
right there
so the lens is able to stick through and
you can see the the led part of
the camera
on
anyway so it's actually
doing pretty well in there i think it
would be pretty hard to get it
especially because the wheels act like a
bumper but i'm thinking of adding like
two little rubber pieces on the front
there just to make sure that it doesn't
get absolutely destroyed
at some point by hitting like a corner
or something like that i could foresee
it getting hit pretty good
so anyway that's what um we have at the
moment for our car i'm not really sure
what else to do with it besides put on a
distance sensor for the rear and so
maybe i'll do that and then show you
guys the results of that um but that's
about it um so anyways if you guys have
any questions or comments feel free to
leave those below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time